それをもうわからない
それでもわからないというならば
例えば原子の中でこの電子というエネルギーは周りに働いてるんですね
それを取り出そうと思うと
すごいエネルギーが必要なんですね
そこで核を核の中に何か違うエネルギーを入れちゃったら
違う走路して鉄砲で撃つように撃っちゃったならば
核は割れちゃうでしょ
割れたらどうなるんですか？ものすごいエネルギーは外に出てしまっちゃうんですね
もうこの今は核反応でね
今やってるのはそういう働きですから
核の中を鉄砲で撃っちゃうでしょうに
撃ったところでそこはちょっと割れてしまっちゃうんです
割れたところで固まっていたエネルギーはもう出て逃げてしまっちゃいます
だから恐ろしいエネルギーなんですよ
だから この私たちは思ってるような
このすごいこの安定した世界ではないんです
この小さなこの腸の中でも
どれほどエネルギーはありますかというと
もう これすごく並のものじゃないんです
ただ 今安定している 特にこの我々強烈に思うエネルギーは
だいたいバッテリーの土のエネルギーなんですけど
例えば音がありますね
私たちの音量できませんんだけど
音も物質なんです 物質ということは
小さい核があるということなんですね
そこですごい音を出しちゃったらどうなるんですか？物は動いて動くわ
壊れるわ そういうケースあるでしょ
音でもうダメになったと
あります 人間には大きな声で喋って
この声何か落としてみようということできませんだけど
でも自然的に何かね すごい音が生まれたら
それでも例えばどこかで大きなダイナマイトとか爆発しちゃったら
音で倒れますよ で あの
何でしたっけ あの あれ
大きな鉄砲なんて言いました？この
すごい大きい大砲 大砲でもたまにこのいろんなお祭りでお礼を通してお守りでしょ
二十一回とかなんとかとか
で 自分はもうそういうなんとかの行事に参加して
政府の行事でしたけど
それで適当な時間でも海を海に向かって大砲をちゃんと撃つんで
大砲のあの音が耳に入った瞬間で
この私の足の下ですか
そのチッとなんかに 誰かにぶん殴られたような感じで感じちゃうんですね
あれは何も別に大砲は全部海にこう向いて撃ってますけどね
僕らはこっちにいますけど
やっぱり音 小さい時 あの
動物園で初めてライオンの吠えを聞いたんですね
読んでことがありますけど
ライオンは王様で 猛獣王様で
この声にはみんな怖がりますよと
ではあったんだけど 本当に実際にライオンが吠える時はやっぱり全部この体も揺れてしまっちゃうんですね
別に怖がったわけじゃないんだから
俺の中にいるライオンで見たこと見た目ない
その時は他のところ見ましたし
いきなりこの体が細胞がもう揺れちゃったんですね
あれはライオンの声吠えだと
なるほどすごいんだ で
初めてこの感じは考えたんだから
音にしたってもかなりのもんなんです
ですから この物が割れたりするのは
やっぱりこの地の小さい核の地のエネルギーが入ったら
物は割れたりすることができます
それで破裂したり パンクしたり
爆発させたりする場合は
風のエネルギーなければいけません
それでこの爆竹ですか
そういう花火とか そういうものの場合は
中でいっぱい空気を作っちゃうんですね
花火の中 もう酸素はいっぱい積み込んじゃって
酸素を燃えるものを入れちゃって
そこで火をつけたら この中に小さな領域の中でこの燃えちゃうでしょ
燃えたらいっぱい空気が生まれる
そこでそれは爆発して花火やらいろんなものは出てくる
音は出てくる 音を出ている
だからダイナマイトの場合は物を壊すことでもできる
というように この物質の世界は変化する
そういう働きはそこでやっぱり火はよく働いてはくれます
いろんな形で 包丁ありますね
あれはもう金属というのは鉄
亜鉛です とにかく鉄と思ったっていいし
何かな でも鉄で何でも切れるわけじゃないんですね
そこでどんな鉄も刃物にはならないんですね
そこで鉄はやっぱり硬くなければいけませんね
硬い硬いというのは この地の元素が大きくなる
大きくなるっていうことなんです
そこで硬くなって硬くて太いと
例えば刃物の切れる部分がものすごく硬いんだと
それぐらいそれだけではなくて
一ミリあるいは二ミリぐらいもう太さがあるんだといったら
何も切れませんでしょ
いくら硬くても 一ミリぐらい二ミリぐらいの幅があったら
この幅があるということは
物質の間を取っているということだから
このアーポーとテージョーがそれなりに働いていることなんですね
そこでそれ研ぐ といでといっても一ミリじゃなくても零点一ミリぐらい細くする
もっと細くする 零点零一ミリぐらいと
これ細くすればするほど
この欠け尾しかなくなっちゃうんで
欠け尾の方がどんどん大きくなって他のもの出ていってるでしょ
それで切れるんです それで他のものを間通っていくんです
他のものの間を通っていっちゃったら
我々は二つのものだと切れたと言うんです
でも穴がなければいけませんよ
ものの間は なんでダイヤがすごく強いと言うんですか
ダイヤはまあ強いことでも
まあまあすごく潰れちゃいますけどね
こうちゃんとやっちゃえば
もう何かでこの金槌でもね
これはまあ割れることは割れますけど
やっぱり強いというのは強いんですね
それはわけはダイヤの分子構造では動きが鈍いんですね
エネルギーはいくらかバランスを取っちゃって
カーボンがね きちんと次の次のカーボンとちょうどうまくつなげてるんですね
ぴったし それでこの このアーポーさんにもテージョーさんにもちょっと無理ですね
働くのは もういわゆる働きをいくらか
もうすごくバランス取ってるんです
だから硬いというふうに言うだけのことなんです
なんでスポンジはすごく柔らかいんですかというと
好き勝手に空気等が動くでしょうに
好き勝手に だから柔らかいんです
そういう風な この なんかえらいそこっぽく単純な話でもあって
すごい難しい話でもあるんです
だからそれは知識人にも知識のない人にもわかる仏教の物質論なんです
知識人が自分の知識のレベルで理解してくださいと
普通の人々は自分の知識レベルで理解してくれ
どっちにしても理解は同じ心理ですよ
ですから この結局はこういう風な物質は存在することはないんです
この長やら薄くやら厚やら糸やら
そういう風なものは存在しない
そこにあるのは基本的な四種類のエネルギーなんです
その四種類のエネルギーの組み合わせによって物質の差が生まれるんです
例えば地の元素がたくさんあると
そのものはかなり重い
風の元素が入っちゃうとかなり大きい
阿婆元素が大きくなってくると
すごく固まって離れなく
一つのひと塊になってしまっちゃう
そこは水を見ればわかります
水があって 水に あの 火のエネルギーを与えてください
そうすると火は変化させますから
あの 阿婆のこの風のバランスを崩しちゃうんですね
で バランスを崩しちゃって
お互いに自由に動くようになってくる
それで水は蒸気になってしまっちゃうんです
水の分子が自由に動くようになってしまう
そこでそれの この一旦上げた火の元素をまた取ってみてください
そうすると蒸気したものは水になってくる
水からまたまた熱をもらうと
動かなくなっちゃって
硬くなって氷になってしまっちゃう
そういうふうな これ それでまた極力またまた火を取っちゃうと
氷も違うものになってしまっちゃうんです
でも我々現代持ってるエネルギーではそれはできないんですね
現代人間が持っているエネルギーでは
やっぱり氷は氷で いくらあの熱を取っても氷で止まっちゃいますけどね
それぐらいの物質論なんです
それは基本物質 それは基本であって
四つのエネルギー 四つの素粒子
この四つの素粒子 なんとなくこのクォークスみたいなもんなんですね
素粒子論でこの素粒子も何か分かってくると
その素粒子はどうやって出来上がるんですか？と考えたところで
クォークスという概念が生まれている
なんか最近クォークスも発見しましたという話も聞きましたけど
僕はなかなか何も読んでないし
なんか何もわかりませんだけど
まあ一応理論で考えるとクォークスというのは発見しにくいものなんですね
いわゆるあると推測はできる
で でもこのクォークスを考えた人々も僕と同じように考えたことは確かなんですね
で 大体この重力というか
このそういうのは離れると弱くなっちゃうんですね
で で それで逆のものでないと何かものは存在しないではないか
ですから 離れれば離れるほどお互いに引っ張られる力が強くなると
お互いに一緒になっちゃったら
先生引っ張られる何もなくなっちゃってゼロになっちゃうんだ
そういうふうなものがなければいけません
最終的には それはクォークスだと
ですから クォークスという素粒子が遠くなればなるほど強烈なエネルギーでお互いに引いてしまうんですね
一緒になったところでゼロで
もう何もない 何もエネルギーはないという風に
ですからまあ概念でしょうと思います
それはまあ なんか四種類ぐらい考えてるみたいでしょうね
まあどういうことかあまりわかりません
ですから あまり嘘言ってはいけませんだから僕も勝手に
で まあ仏教で言ってるこの地水火風っていうのも
なんとなくそんなようなもので
決して引き離すことは不可能なんです
引き離すことは不可能
ですから いつでもこの四つはセットで
地水火風はワンセットであるんです
セットなんですけど 地一と火一と風一と水一じゃないんです
その順番はもうバラバラ
だからいろんなものがあるんです
地一人 例えば水は十個ぐらいあって
風がもうまたもう五ぐらいがあって
まあ火も適当にもうまあ六四ぐらいあれば
まあ大体水のようなものが生まれるんじゃないかなとかね
例えば石なんか取ってみたら
やっぱり硬いでしょうし
重いでしょうし そうするとやっぱりそこで地の割り当てはすごく大きくて
それで粉になってる小麦粉に水を入れちゃったら
水の場合は あの 水の元素の量が多いんですね
その水の元素の量が多い水が
水の元素の量がすごい少ない
お互いにほとんど引っ張らない
小麦粉に入れたところで
小麦粉の中の割り当てが変わるでしょ
そうすると普通の あの
あれなんて言いますか
一旦練って終わったところのものに
小麦粉 生地？パン？ん？日本語ではどうというんですけど
そういうものは出てくるでしょうね
[笑い]ですから まあまあ
うどん作る時でもね まあまあ
なんていうのは 蕎麦作る時でも同じこと
粉があって それにまあ適当に水を入れて割り当てを変える
そうすると まあラーメンもうどんもそばもできるようになると
そこででも硬いでしょうし
それで水にまたもっと水を入れてゆったりすると
また柔らかいということも生まれてくる
その柔らかさというのは
やっぱり熱の変化によってまた生まれてくるということなんです
毎日我々は体験している世界なんですね
毎日体験している現象の物質の世界
だから仏教の違うところは全然顕微鏡も要りませんね
直接それ知るんですよ
別に何か道具を使って知るより
例えば今 このいろんなものを今いっぱい道具作ってますね
例えばこの甘さどれぐらいありますかと
塩はどれぐらいありますし
何だかんでもこのいろんなメーターで測ってるでしょ
メーターで数字が出て
これは甘いんだ これは酸っぱいだ
これはしょっぱいだと決めるんだけど
我々が言うのは まあやっぱり直接舐めてみて
これは甘い これは酸っぱいというぐらいのことなんですね
ですから 直接我々はそれを体験しているんです
地水火風 それはセットであります
セットの割り当ては違う
それで物質はいろんな物質が生まれてくる
そこで我々は物質を変化しようとするときでも
この直接我々にはできないんだと
例えば柔らかい水があって
その水を石のように硬いものにしたいんだと
重いものにしたいんだと
そうすると あの地入れればいいんです
地の元素の この地の元素のエネルギーを流れていけばそれで終わりです
でも 純粋に地のエネルギーの元素を流し込むことはできないんです
なぜならば 独立して地の元素のエネルギーはないんだから
いつでもやるのは地水火風のセットでですね
そこで地水火風のセットの中で
地の元素の割り当てはすごい大きいものを選んだ方がいいんです
そうすると水が固まる可能性あります
油とか固めて捨てるというものあるでしょう
で その人々は科学的に考えていますけど
仏教から見ればこの論理なんです
温かい天ぷら油に何かを粉を入れると
入れたところでお互いに引っ張って止まると
引っ張るエネルギーは大きくなる
そうすると油が固める
そんなことです ですから
それをもっと基本的に言えば
どんなものはどんなものにも変化することは論理上は可能なんです
例えば鉄を温めなくても
水のように流れるものにすることは可能ですけど
そうすると鉄ではないんです
それにはやっぱり水の元素のエネルギーさえ流し込めばいいんだけど
不可能ですね 不可能のこの 4つはいつも
では一緒にいるんだから
で 我々はそれでもまあもう諦めないでいろんなものを作ってるんです
例えば鉄自体は柔らかい
それで物は作れません
それでスチールというものは作ってるでしょ
スチールはどうやって作りますか？鉄に他のものを入れちゃう
鉄の方から見れば不純物なんですけど
立場 鉄の立場から見れば
まあカーボンとかね 酸素
炭素とかね そういう炭素とか不純物を入れちゃう
炭素は持ってるんですね
このちょっとしたこの地のエネルギーは余計に
それとそれと鉄のと繋げたところで
鉄ではなくて鉄はなんですが
スチールと我々言葉というものは生まれている
そういうふうに変化はもうずっと毎日我々はやってます
普通の家で料理作って食事を作ってしてるお母さんたちも
そういう変化はしているんです
小麦粉をケーキにしちゃうし
硬い米をご飯にしてしまっちゃうし
そういうのも同じ変化なんです
そういうことで 地水火風の話はでは終わります
で 何か問題ありますか？まあ問題というよりは
いろいろ意見とかあるならば
もっと話はしやすいんですね
まあ私も育ちが全く違いますから
環境も文化もね 全部 だから僕ら僕だけの思考方法で理解できると思ってないんです
ですから そんなところはみんなこれだけ皆様の持ってる知識で理解してもいいんです
僕は他のところで喋ってる仏教はもうそれはやっぱりいけないんです
自分の固定概念捨てないと
でもこういう風な物質的な科学みたいな話の場合は
皆様はすでに持っている知識を使って考えてください
さっき音も音もこれを使ってきてるって言いましたですね
そこ考えられないですかね
まあそれは後落ち着きます
音に重さもあるでしょうし
何かにぶつかっちゃったらものは変化するしね
やっぱりただ軽いだけですよ
空気はわかるでしょ 空気と同じものなんですね
光は  光も重さありますよ
あの だいたい だから仏教ではそういうふうに言ってますけど
今科学的な発展の立場から考えると
素粒子だけの流れが宇宙にはあるんですね
そういうものはこの太陽にも関係なく
宇宙も地球にも関係なく
星にも何も関係なく 自分勝手に流れちゃうんですね
いわゆるこの宇宙は膨張してるんだと分かってる人そういうことでしょう
だからこの宇宙 ビッグバンの時は出ていた
この宇宙何々線なんとかっていうものがありまして
それは一番最初に出来上がったエネルギーなんです
それはまあずーっともう出ていくんですね
遠く遠く遠く そこで計算して
遠くなった 遠くなったということで
あの やっぱり宇宙は膨張してるんだとかね
言ってるし そこでまあ逆に計算してとかね
まあそこでこの素粒子の場合だったら
もう関係なく流れますけど
その場合は重さがあるかないかとかも別の問題ですけどね
重さはいつでもありますね
重さっていうのは別にある働きなんですね
だから音には働きがありますかという働きがあるでしょ
とにかく  でもまあ基本的のね
音は波ですよね これも根本的なものは波ですよね
波動ですよね  これ基本波なんです
根本的なものはね 波動ですけど
音は純粋な波ですよね
我々の世界ではね  光も光波という波ですよね
それは波自身の  だからそこら辺曖昧なんですね
いわゆる波で見ると波であって
でも何かを波を波を作らないといけないということになると
ただの波ではなくて やっぱり太陽から何か出てきて
それは波で きてくる ですから
その 2つの立場で科学者が見ているんですね
波だけで見るとエネルギーだけであって
もう例えば何か球があって
球はこうやって波を押す場合は
もう球があって 球が波が押すかもう波がだけやるかという
そういうふうに どっちかとはまあ僕もあんまり科学わかりませんだけど
ではあの普通の世界では全部そう分けてますよね
粒子と波動というふうに
それまあ素粒子を考える物質物理学ではそういう分け方なんです
それは一般的な物理学なんです
量子力学の世界ではそう分けてないんですね
はい  一般的な物理学と量子学
結局その2つを足すと
そのチョークがありますよね
このチョークを僕は今見たわけで
そのチョークがチョークに当たった光が僕の目の中に入って
光という物質が僕の僕の目の中に入ったことは認識して
そこにチョークがあるという判断をしましたけど
量子学ではこの光というものを物質と扱っているわけですね
だけどそこに先生が持ってらっしゃるチョークという物質があるわけですね
普通の物理学 そこの分け目
分け方がわからないです
それがわかればこの知のエネルギーを理解はできるんですけど
この光が向こう側から来て
こっちぶつかって目に入るということは
この普通の一般のレベルの科学で言ってることで
それはそれなりに証拠はあるような感じますけど
別に我々対応するものじゃないんです
それはそれで それから
この光のエネルギーはここにぶつかる
ぶつかっても何のことなく
その光のその光のエネルギーは中村さんの目に入ったならば
中村さんがこれを見ているんであって
これを見ていることにはならないんですね
でも これチョークを見るとチョークを見るんですね
チョークを見るということは
こちらからあるエネルギーがここにぶつかる
ぶつかったところで ここではエネルギーの変化を起こす
量的にも質的に変化を起こしたところで
余分なものは出ていく
ですから ここに当たる光とここから反射している光は量的質的に違うんです
そこで量的質的に違う光が目に入ったところで
今日だと頭で認識する
それからこの量子的な立場で考えると
これに光当たるたびに
このチョークは量的に質的に変化していくんです
瞬間でもものは同じものではいられないんです
ですから 私たちはこのチョークを見ても見なくても
ここから光が当てておくと
それは変化していくんです
変化して このエネルギーはこっちぶつかって
これから違うのが出ていく
それでそのエネルギーは壁やいろんなところに吸収されたり
それと壁が変化していったりする
それで私が入っちゃったら
私も一部取ってしまっちゃうエネルギーを
それだけのことで それで私が取った分は壁には行かないんですね
だから  ということは そこにそのチョークは存在しているだけで
そのうちに物質としてなくなりますよということですか
そうそうそう なくなります
そのエネルギーの発散量と時間の関係というのが
見た私も同じことで 何か目に光が当たったっていうことは
エネルギーの量質が変わったということなんですね
その変わったことによって認識可能認識機能が生まれてしまっちゃうんです
だから ものを目を開けて見た瞬間で
私というこの構造はもう変化しているんです
かすかにでも音が耳に入っちゃったら
そこでこのエネルギーの塊のエネルギーのバランスは崩れちゃう
その分 余分なエネルギーは外に出さなくちゃいけないし
そこで自分が変化する
そこまで ちょっと私はこうやって手を打つと音が出る
その音皆様の耳に入る
入った瞬間 皆様の体はもう全部変わってるんです
で こう音を打った瞬間で私ももう変化してるんです
それで量的でよく分かります
例えば私は1時間喋ると
まあ体がガタガタで疲れてるんでしょうし
2時間  3時間  4時間喋るともう倒れちゃうかもしれませんし
ということは どうせ物質的な変化が起こってるってことなんですね
それで聞く時でも同じなんですね
ちょっと1時間何か聞いたんだからって言って
我々には感じる変化はないかもしれませんだけど
同じことを 1 日 20 20時間と聞くと
ありとあらゆるところで変化を起こす
胃の調子が悪くなるし
肺の血液の循環が変になっちゃうし
いろいろあるんです ですから
もういつでも変化するんです
それはどうしようも止まれません
ここに私がいるということさえとんでもない幻覚であるんだと
それにつうじゃ 煩悩っていうのはそういうところで生まれてるんだ
それがなかったら煩悩はないっていうのはそういう話ですね
地水火風全てが瞬間の変化という
何？ 地水火風全てが  そうです
うん  瞬間で変わる  瞬間で変わる
そう なんでも変わってしまった
これですね 粗い物質だから我々は見えてるって言うんですね
空気は見えないんですよね
地水火風で空気が空気は空気というものね
酸素が あの空気ありますけど
見えませんよね 光はなくても我々の目では見えない
物質の我々の体やこの見えるのは
物質にその知の要素とか
そういう要素が強いというか
そういう特定のものに
になるわけですよね 酸素でもこの空気も変化してますよね
当然光が当たるんだから当然変化してる
それは見えてない その変化は我々は見えないんだよね
先生の顔は見える これも見える
ということは こういう物質的な
こういう知の要素が強いとか
そういう特定のものが出てくるってことですね
だからそれは組み合わせにより組み合わせですね
だから見える机でも組み合わせ変わっちゃったら見えなくなっちゃう
だから見えるっていうこと
そんな大したことじゃないんだけど
それはもうあるエネルギーは目の目の膜でぶつかるというだけのことで
ただそれだけのことですけどね
聞こえるっていうのも
なんか超音波でそれがあれなんで聞こえないというのか
レベルが我々の体にはあるから
だから我々は音だ 光だというのは
どんなチャネルで見るかということだけであって
別に音は存在する 光が存在することじゃないんです
例えば音でも目で認識したら
それはもう見えることなんです
そこで太陽の光は我々の耳で認識できると思ったら
もう太陽がある限りうるさくてしょうがなくなっちゃうんです
光を放って耳で感じているんだから
だからただのエネルギーの地水火風の流れがある
いろんな流れがある その数え切れない流れの中で
一部は我々は目で取る
一部は耳で認識する 一部は舌で認識する
一部は鼻で認識する 一部は体で認識する
そのほんの一部だけで
またいろんなエネルギーの地水火風の流れはもうどこまであるかわからないほどあるんです
ですから たまたま我々は一部だけ知っている
それに世界と好き勝手に言う
ですから 世界やら人やら全部妄想概念というのはそういうわけで
我々は作る世界であると
そこで私と 犬がここにいるんだと言うと
同じ場所にいるでしょうに
だからそこでいろんな地水火風の流れがありまして
そこで私はその流れのほんの一部を目
耳 鼻から体から感じている
その同じところに犬も目
耳 鼻 体からそういうものを感じている
でも犬の方が耳がすっごく鋭いんだから
私は知らない世界を知っている
目がすごい悪いんだから
私は知ってる世界は知らない
鼻がすっごい鋭いんだから
また私は知らない世界を知っている
そこで皮膚はもう毛で覆われているんだから
私は知ってる世界は知らない
例えば寒さとかそれほど感じない
冬でも平気だから 犬は
そこで犬は自分知ってる情報で
これは世界だと これは客観的な世界だと
本当にああいうところでああいう音があるんだと
あの あの 例えば犬にはこっちいて
あの洗面器じゃなくて
あの洗う場所にあるものの匂いは嗅げますから
例えば犬の世界で我々は言葉でもうもう中村さん
田中さんって名前つけてるでしょ
犬は人をどうやって認識しますか？匂いでしょう
ですから もし犬が言葉を喋れるならば
あの犬語だったらいっぱい匂い語あるんです
数え切れないほど 人間の世界ではいっぱい名前あるでしょ
それ耳で感じてるんだから
田中やらいろいろ名前あるように
もし犬も言語を発達したならば
全部香り 香り 匂い 匂い
匂い 匂い 匂い 言葉です
そういうふうになるんです
それは犬の世界ですから
もし犬は学校なんか作っちゃったら
全部匂い学になっちゃうんですね
化学 物理学ではなくて
ありとあらゆる匂い学になっちゃうんです
認識 そうすると認識で物質全部変わっちゃうということになっちゃいます
認識で  こっちの僕からの認識でチョークがチョークでなくなっちゃうことになりませんか
引き換えに考えると  ちょっと理屈がわかりませんですけど
それは当然ね そういう理屈には成り立つんだけど
それは一応この世界として法則を決めておかない
この世界でこれがチョークだよという形を申し渡しをしてこい
チョークに見える 犬がこれチョークを見たらチョークではない
これは単なる物質かもしれないということになってしまう
だから一応仮の名前として
チョークとして我々がつけることになって
これがチョークではないよということだった人
という認識によって変化してしまうだろうと
これはチョークじゃないじゃないでしょうかということですから
そういうことじゃないですか
うん だからその時でもやっぱりチョークに我々は何となくやっぱりこだわりがあるということであって
人間にはチョークですけど
やっぱりよく考えるとチョークでなくなっちゃうんではないかなと
そこまで思わなくたって構いません
なぜかというと 別にチョークにこだわらなくてもいい
我々には認識できるチャンネルは６つがあります
そのチャンネルには入られることを許されているものは決まってあって
これテレビやらラジオやらと全く同じことだから
いくらテレビがあったっても
もう入る もう電波はもう決まってるんだから
例えば僕らの国々に使ってるテレビなんかこっち持ってきたっても全然見えませんから
その代わりにやっぱり電波を受けますよ
頑張ると そうすると さあさあやら1000やら
いろんなグニャグニャやら見えるんだけど
1つも人の映像は映れませんし
そういう風に私たちも一つのテレビ台みたいに考えて
いろいろチャンネルは６つしか
日本のテレビ局ぐらいありますけど
まあもう６つしかない
それにも決まってるものは入る
それ我々はその中で幻想の世界をつくる
我々にはチョークがありますって
人間には で それも一つの妄想概念であって
幻想であって でも妄想概念といっても
なんでチョークにチョークだと思ってますかね？なんでチョークを見て
これはウナギだ これは美味しいだと思って食べないんですかね
幻想だったらどんなものでもいいでしょうに
で これは紅茶のあれだと思って
いい これはもう他の爆弾だと思ってもいいし
幻想だからどんな幻想でも作れるでしょ
でもそこら辺でちょっとしたことがあるんですね
幻想を作るために何かエネルギーを私の体に伝わってきて
それで私の体で変化 反応を起こさなくちゃいけないんですね
私の妄想概念はその変化
反応に基づくんですから
これを見ると見る人間がこれ紅茶だと決めてしまっている
病気になったら まあちょっと違いますけど
高熱が出したりすると
うん そこら辺に物質はもう一応仮にあるように考えなさいと仏教で言ってるんですね
空は大乗仏教で全ては空やというふうに言わない
大乗仏教ですべて絶対実体としては空であると実体はないといったところで
なんか空論になってしまうんですね
空想論 でまあ例えばこれは空であって何もないんだと言ってもいいんだけど
私にとっては これはもう紅茶の缶詰めとして言うんですか
紅茶の缶としてもう見えちゃうんですね
これ 空であって実体がないものになるならば
じゃあこれからこれは美しい
なんか桃の桃の桃として見ようと
あるいはスイカとして見ようではないか
メロンとして見ようではないかと思ってメロンになっちゃって
これで美味しいメロン食べればいいのに
それは不可能ですね ですから
この我々の妄想概念も
このエネルギーの働き次第で
変化しちゃってるんですね
そんな難しいことじゃないんです
ですから 人間はチョークはチョークで見てしまっちゃう
それは最初の言葉で我々を説明しましたからね
なんて言いますか 世俗帯
これは世俗帯認識 そういうふうに認識するんだ
世俗帯は実際の心理の世界だと思って
我々はありとあらゆる苦しみの存在の問題を作っている
ですから 世俗帯は世俗帯で
何の意味もない もう何てこだわらない世界になった
犬は犬で世界を作っているし
この空を飛んでいるハヤブサとかいろいろすごい鋭い感覚の動物いるんだからね
そういうのはそれなりの世界を作っていて
誰も正しいわけでもなく
間違ってるわけでもなく
それぞれ勝手にやってるんだ
この子供がこのおもちゃで遊んでることと同じなんですね
ちっちゃな子供はおもちゃで遊ぶときは
それはもう子供にとっては本物の世界なんです
ぬいぐるみなんかは本当に生きているんです
もう間違ってでも足で蹴っ飛ばしちゃいけないんです
怒られるんです 子供 でしょうがないんです
そういうふうに世界は出来上がっちゃうんです
アポっていうところなんですけども
アポ  吸いとか吐くとか引っ張るとかくっつけるっていう働きですけども
その時には例えば冷たいとか
そういうのは考えてもいいんですか？同じように
例えば定常ですね 火ですね
火は物変化させるって働きだというふうにおっしゃったんですが
例えば熱さとかそういうことを考えていいんでしょうか
大変いいです いいんです
アポの場合は冷たい これは全部定常なんです
定常はかなりこのまあ働きもんで
だから僕は熱だと思ってもいいと思ったんです
教えた覚えがあるんです
定常は気でもいいし 熱でもいいんです
変化でもいいんです 変化させることでもいいんです
ですから 暑い寒いと感じるのは気なんですって
熱なんですね  例えばバイオはですね
これは引き離す働きっていうことですけど
これは風っていうと軽さっていうイメージもあるんですが
それはどうなんでしょうか
で 実際もうこれからのまだ始まったばっかでね
このスタートの時点で
要するにそれぞれの要素の次第について
それぞれの人が持っている
そのたくさんイメージとして膨らませちゃって
将来的にいいのかな あるいは一つアポがくっつけるだけっていう風に狭く限定して捉えた方が後々いいのかなってちょっと思って
今お話しました  ですけど
まあどっちとも同じことっていうことで
一応わかるためには限定して見た方が自分のためにはなるんです
自分がしっかり理解したことになって
それで心は清らかになってしまうんです
あくまでも仏教学っていうのは
ただ頭良くなるためのもの
ただではなくて 頭良くなるためのではなくて
心が良くなるためのものなんですね
ですから そういう目的は少々違う
ですから この限定して厳密に見た方が
まあ自分のためにはなるんです
大きいスケールで考えたってしても
別に悪くはないのです
それは人の個人で持っている能力で決めればいいし
それからこの今の問題はここから生まれたんですね
一応この我々は軽い 柔らかい
硬いということは こういう辺で考えるんではないかと
本当のところは 柔らかい
硬いというものは体の感覚なんです
柔らかい 硬い 重いというものは
全部体の感覚なんです
その体の感覚というのは
体に伝導する物質 エネルギーなんですね
体に伝導できるエネルギーはバッテリーなんです
硬さのエネルギーなんですね
失速量 だからこの失速量を作るエネルギーは体に触れるんです
そこで頭で我々は計算する
質量の方が少ない場合は
これ柔らかいやふわふわしているんだ
いわゆるパタウィが少ないんです
石一つ左手で持って スポンジ一つ一つ右手で持って触ってみたところで
目を閉じた人でもこれは石だと決める
なぜならば そちらには硬さが重さがあって
質量が高くて スポンジは質量が少なくてパタウィが少ないんです
そこで軽いという 柔らかいという
空気は感じないんです
和様は 例えば空気あるでしょ
空気を体に触れたらわかるでしょ
空気があるんだと でも体に触れるのは空気の和様の幻想ではなくて
地の幻想なんです そこら辺は後で順番ちゃんと説明があります
こういう次第が本質はエネルギーであるということでしたけども
そうしますと心の働きというのもエネルギーだっていうことでしょうか
そうしますと お互いにエネルギー同士であれば
当然影響し合えるっていうこともありますかね
つまり 心の持ち方をもって
こういう次第を変化させることによって
いわば現象界というのを変えていく
いわゆるそれは神通とか超能力っていう世界の話に結びついてくると思うんですが
そういうこともちょいちょい可能だみたいな話になってくるんですか
別に可能になっても構いませんし
まあ別にまあ  そこは行きたい
そこ行きたいんだけどな
心のエネルギーの働きは違う
私はアビダンマは心から始まりますけど
それは全部置いておいて
六処から始めたんですね
心の勉強になっちゃったら
もう何年かかるか ちょっと心配で
いくらか何かきちんと終わって終わりたい
僕はけじめつけたいんです
一応物質だけで終わりましたと
言いたいんだから 一番簡単な分かりやすい物質論で始めたんです
心はエネルギーなんですけど
そのエネルギーの在り方が違うんですね
ですから このだから物質は時空
時空関係作っちゃうんですね
物質のエネルギーは固まると物が出ちゃがんですね
心ではそうはないんですね
そこでお互いにまた変な影響あるんですね
変なではなくて このもうなんとかある形の影響あるんですね
また それをそれなりに後で説明します
おっしゃっていることはまたそうかもしれません
と言ったって曖昧ですけど
まあいわゆるやればできるもんなんです
現象の現象は何でも変化できます
ただ エネルギーの流れを変化すればいいんです
今は科学者はみんなやってるの同じことなんです
病気になっちゃったら
ある体のエネルギーの流れがいろいろ変わると
それで薬というものを入れちゃって
またちょっと変化させちゃう
それで治ったという 病気ということ
だから結局何の意味もないんですよ
病気になったというのは人間勝手に考えることで
別に病気という現象はあるわけじゃないし
それある体の感覚があって
その感覚は変わる それ変わった状態は自分で好ましくない
それで病気だという それでまたこの
感覚に変わってもらう
で 治ったという ですから
かなり痛み止めとか使うでしょうにお医者さんたちっていうのは
あれ えらく人間だましてるんですね
頭痛とかなんかあったら
もうすぐ何か飲んじゃうでしょ
別に頭痛治ったわけじゃなくて
その感覚を感じないようにするじゃん
あ 治りましたと 風邪の場合も同じであって
全然風邪は病気で言うならば治ってないんですね
ただ 嫌な気持ちだけ感じないようにしてくれると
堂々と我々の体を切ったりするんだけど
お医者さんが もう痛みだけ感じないようにする
そうすると全然もう平気で物を取ったり入れ替えたり
平気なことやっちゃうんですね
そういう風にこの病気だれあれだこれだいう場合も
やっぱりまあエネルギーの交換であって
だからまあ何でも可能なんですね
何でも可能なんです でも法則がある
法則に則って何でも可能
それはこれで これは決して
例えばこれはビールだとは思うことは誰にも不可能なんです
でもこれは紅茶だよと思うことも幻想なんですが
でもじゃあビールだと思ってくださいって言ったら
それは可能です そこに法則があります
仏教ではこの四諦ですよね
他に例えば先ほどちょっとおっしゃいましたけど
例えばアキハ社で五代だとか
さらにジーバで六代だとか
いろんな考え方ありますが
仏教でこの四諦だということを主張するっていうか
真理だとして言うっていうのは
どういうふうにして悟ったんでしょうか
分かったんでしょうか
また 私たちが自分でこう今教えていただいて
アビダルマで教えていただいて
この全世界というのは四諦のこの 4つのエネルギーだっていうことで
あーぶったということで教えていただいて
こう そうなんですかって受け入れるわけですけども
もしヴィパッサナーとかなんかそういう瞑想で
こうやって こう四諦が正しいっていうふうな
そういう知識 認識に到達するでしょうか
します  そのやり方っていうか
とばっちりを教えていただければ
毎日教えてるんだから
みんな嫌になるほど教えてるんだからね
地水火風のエネルギーを
私は状況として入れてるっていう考え方で
状況？ 情報  私は毎日念じてるのは地水火風なんですね
結局光だの言葉のなんだかんだ言って
地水火風だけを情報として
そうそうそうそうそう
そういうことなんです
この地水火風を本当に分かりやすく言ったと
例えばイワサキさんが頭をかくでしょ？たまにでも
その頭をかく時は何を感じて認識してますか？手から頭に入る地のエネルギーなんです
硬く感じるんじゃないんですか？あと
空気で感じますか？空気として感じないでしょ？やっぱり硬さで感じる
それで目で感じるエネルギーはまだちょっと違うんです
それはあの これ絵書絵書という絵し絵し式？ウパーダヤルーパ
まだ4つ まだありますよ
28ですね まだ28あります
まあまあ4つ終わっただけですから
まだ24残ってるんです
絵し式の場合はね 何が見えるか
何が聞こえるかということをね
説明します 一応あの 今おっしゃったように
このいろんなこの5台
6台  10台とかね まあいろいろ言ってますけど
その ただ仏教の違うところは
まあ物質の世界ときちんと迷惑に分けて純粋に勉強するというか
理解すると ごちゃ混ぜにしないことなんですね
例えばインドにしたっても
日本にしたってもごちゃ混ぜ論でしょ
例えば僕にもよく反対されましたから
この心 心というと やっぱり私たちは心と体は離れないものだとかね
全部一つだと思ってますよとか
偉そうに言うんだよ 本人はすごい尊いことを思ってると思ってますけど
ごちゃ混ぜで物事は理解できないんです
やっぱり分析した方が明確に
これはこの働き これはこの働き
わざわざ分析するものだから
もともと一緒にあることは当たり前の話なんです
私にはここに体があって心があるんだと
それは離れないものだということは当たり前であって
それでも分かりませんだから分析する
ですから 物質の勉強する場合は
認識 認識世界に関する何にも使わない
使わないで物質の働きだけ理解する
心の働き勉強すると きちんと心の働きを勉強する
そうすると問題は丁寧に解決するんです
分析してみなさいということ
例えばアーカシャもあって
そこにアートマンもあると言っちゃったら
もうごちゃ混ぜなんですね
物質の世界も精神の働きもごちゃ混ぜになっちゃうんですね
プルシャもあると言っちゃったら
またもまたも なんでそこと仏教は違いますか？例えばプルシャがいるんだと
プルシャっていうのは普遍的にすべてのものを支配している精神的な魂みたいな神みたいなエネルギーなんですね
じゃあ我々はどこまで探検したっても
そんなエネルギーは見つかりますか？見つかりません
だから見つからないものはなんで仮定しましたかと
仏教の違うところは見つからないものは仮定から仮定は外すんです
で 物語があります ある石があります
その石はどんなものに触れちゃっても
そのものは金になるんです
不思議な石 そこである人がいて
このこの人にちゃんと情報を教えてもらって
こういう石があるんだと
それ見つかったらあなたの全部
あの 何でしたっけ 苦しみは消えちゃいます
もう金持ちになりますよ
触れちゃったらそれは金になりますから
それで探しましょうと
それでその人はこの まあ金属のベルトを着けて
それで分かりませんから
この石と触れてみたら
もうダメ これじゃダメと
これダメと そういう風にずーっと片っ端から歩いて
あれとあらゆる石を自分のベルトに触れてみるんですね
触れてみるたびに その人はこれじゃない
これじゃない これじゃないと
この金に触れたら金になる石を探していくんですね
それでどうせ途中で死にますけどね
そのストーリーを僕はちょっと強引に変化します
で そこでそのやり方 この人は実際に経験するのは
石はベルトに触れてみる
何の変化もない と事実なんですね
でも その人の理解は この石ではなく
他の石はベルトに触れたら金になるんですよという理解なんですね
そこで私たちから見れば
仏教の立場から見れば
いえ その理解ではなくて
今まで石に触れたんだ
触れた触れた石は全部全く変化しなかったと
一応触れてみても ですから
大勢の石を見て そこで石をベルトに触れても
金になるところ何にもなりませんとということは真実です
その人はいまだに見つかってないにも関わらず
いえ この石ではなくて違う石ですよという
きちんと決めつけてるんです
だから 死ぬまで探し求めている
それで途中で当然死ぬと
それで魂 アートマン 神様
ブラフマンとかね そういう絶対的な存在というものは
人間の小さな認識から見ればどうしても認識不可能なものだが
例えば無限的なものであって
有限と言うんですか この
限りのない存在を小さなもので把握することはもうどうしても不可能であるし
そこで小さなものは何であんなものあるかと思ったことさえもおかしいし
それは自分の小ささから反応した出てきた反応だけなんですね
小さいものについては
大きいというものはどうせ出来上がりますから
ですから この短いものには長いものがついてくるし
長い恐ろしいものにはすごいそうでないものがついてくるし
この論と反論ですか 物と
物質と反物質ですか そういうふうにまあよく出てきやがっちゃいますから
それは頭の悪いの概念で
やっぱり人間作ったもので体験できない
だからあるともないとも言わない
体験不可能 認識不可能
それで終わらない じゃあ幻想と法則として見てみようと
法則として見るとありえないと
因果法則から見れば絶対ありえない
因縁に関係なく存在は存在しないんだから
だからありえないと っていうのはしっかり自分で分かりますね
瞑想を通っていくと 信仰ではなくて
ただ私は仏教で生まれたんだから仏教はありがたいという気持ちではなくて
ただもうありえないと
別に私は仏教徒だから堂々とバカを人のこういう概念なんかバカにしてるわけじゃなくて
本当に自分にとっては正直なところでバカバカらしいんですね
なんとバカなことを言ってるんですかと
人間のくせに とぐらいほどバカな概念もいっぱいあるんですね
こういう超自然的な概念の中に
全部否定するんじゃなくて
この今おっしゃっているように
神通力やら超能力やら
そういうものは法則に則っているとあり得る話はいっぱいあるんです
いくら超能力であろうか
やっぱり法則の中で働くと
で とにかくこの他の宗教でもこの精神科学はアカシックとか
それからまあ また何でしたっけ
この私服も入れてるんですね
で いうとやっぱりごちゃ混ぜであって
私服やら感覚やら苦しみやら
そういうのはやっぱり人間のね
気持ちの世界ですから
それは別に勉強した方がいいということ
心理学と物理学は混ぜませんね
こんなのやるやる気やるやれませんからね
やっぱり物理 フィジックスですか
学校に行って物理学でいろいろどうやってものは変化するか
どうやってエネルギーは変わるか
そこは相手で心理学が入るとこはないんです
まあそんな大した問題じゃないね
別に 大して ただ ただ説明しやすくするためのもの
じゃあ時間は随分 では
どうもありがとうございました
ありがとうございました